first we'll start with some breaking
news a fire has broken out on an italian
flanked ferry traveling between greece
and italy
237 passengers and 51 crew members are
believed to have been on board the euro
ferry olympia when the fire reportedly
started near the greek island of corfu
there are no reports of deaths or
serious injury the greek coast guard has
been carrying out a rescue operation
we can join anthony carasava who is a
freelance journalist in the greek
capital athens welcome to dw and what
more can you tell us
well actually there's a massive
ongoing rescue operation as we speak as
you said
all passengers and crew members have
been evacuated they evacuated at the
orders of the captain who sent them on
lifeboats and now they are all being
tugged to the nearby island of of corfu
that said however we have no death so
far uh one person injured
um and but the fire still
um is raging it has engulfed this
massive
uh ferry and huge plumes of smoke are
covering the nearby island of corfu even
as far off as um albania uh now uh again
there are some three coast guard vessels
that are there um trying to oversee
additional potential rescues of of
people who may be left on board um uh
there is also assistance from nearby
commercial vessels fishermen who have
all joined in this massive operation
helicopters and also an italian vessel
as you said because the incident because
the fire broke out very close uh between
greek and italian waters obviously the
biggest fear right now
and from what we're hearing from witness
accounts is that because uh they suspect
that the fire broke out from the garage
of the ferry that there may be some
lorries uh who may be trapped in there
and worst yet um
this is a route where we see a lot of
stowaways a lot of refugees sneaking in
these vessels to try and make an escape
uh further west into europe um and uh
you know their fear that perhaps there
may be refugees on board
okay thank you so much for that uh
comprehensive uh round up uh anthony
carlos
uh in uh athens thank you
you